- All right. Hi, everybody.
Thank you for coming. I'm Steve Pitti.
I'm the Director of the RITM Center,
and faculty in history,
American studies, and ER&M.
We're really excited today
to host this showcase
of student research
from the summer of 2022.
As everybody here knows,
these projects are some
of the many projects
that RITM had the chance
to support this past year.
We sponsored 37 student research projects
in the summer of 2022.
Those who've received funding,
including people in this
room, traveled far and wide,
deepened their work on
undergraduate and graduate projects,
prepared for senior theses and MA theses,
and worked on chapters of
their doctoral dissertations.
We were delighted this year
to support students working
toward their degrees
in the Graduate School of Arts
and Sciences in Yale College,
and also in many of Yale's
professional schools.
We've had the opportunity
over the last six years
to support the completion
of many student projects
by helping awardees to get to
archives and research sites
where they needed to be to
advance their scholarship.
Past recipients of these research awards
have written prize-winning
dissertations and articles
and completed their degrees,
which is just as important.
I'll mention too, to all of you,
that we're currently accepting research
and conference travel
applications in RITM for the fall
with an early October deadline.
So, check out our weekly newsletter
for more information about
that if you haven't seen it.
You can sign up for the newsletter
if you're not already
signed up at ritm.yale.edu
by clicking on the link on the webpage
that says, "Stay connected."
So today, we'll be hearing
about summer research projects,
as you know.
Each of our presenters
has just three minutes
to describe their summer research.
And then we'll,
we'll then ask members of the audience
if any one person has a
brief question to ask,
and we'll give that
presenter a brief moment
to respond to that question.
This is the interest of
keeping things moving,
and we will be moving fast
and demanding concision and clarity
from both presenters and audience members.
But I really do hope that
everyone here enjoys themselves
and that you'll join us after
the program right out here
in the lounge area for some
relaxing food and drink,
where we will not rush you
and hold you to three minutes
to finish your empanada or whatever
and that you'll continue
the conversation there
and ask more questions of one another.
So, I think this should be a lot of fun.
And with that, I wanna
turn this over to Amanda.
(audience clapping)
- Okay. Can I start?
Okay.
Embarking on my summer internship
in Puerto Rico with the Archivo General,
I wanted to find connections
between the island
and my specific region
of interest, Connecticut,
as it pertains to Puerto Rican diaspora.
My reasons for going were
also a little selfish.
Being a Puerto Rican
raised on the mainland,
I've always wondered whether
I could claim Puerto Rico
as a site of belonging.
Participating in this internship
then fulfilled both a personal dream
of spending extended time on the island
and a professional dream
of conducting research
in Puerto Rico.
The internship with Archivo
General in San Juan,
a collaboration between Yale,
my alma mater, Rutgers University,
and the University of Puerto Rico
included five other student interns,
Ana Calderon, Gabriel Rivera Cotto,
Rosa Cordero, Monica de
Jesus and Veronica Munoz.
Led by director Hilda Ayala
and archivist Pedro Roig,
we sorted through documents
from the Puerto Rico Industrial
Development Corporation
or PRICO, which under Operation Bootstrap,
provided tax exemptions
to mainland businesses
in the 1940s through the 1990s
that opened factories in Puerto Rico
to rapidly industrialize the island
and stimulate its economy.
Multiple companies took advantage
of this colonial capitalist project,
including quite a few from Connecticut.
I found correspondence
with the Hamilton Manufacturing Company,
likely a recording equipment
manufacturer here in New Haven,
the M Hart Corporation in Hartford,
Union Carbide, which is a
chemical corporation in Danbury,
the US Time Corporation, or
watchmakers in Waterbury,
and the Orange Pulp Company,
Valve Corporation of America,
and Warnaco Inc, all in Bridgeport.
In addition to making
these Connecticut Puerto Rico connections,
I also got to visit the (speaking Spanish)
at UPR's Rio Piedras campus in my off time
to explore one of my
other research interests,
Puerto Rican student activism
and education reform.
I collected data of a
student-led strike in 1981
over tuition hikes at UPR,
data which I anticipate using
in a future journal article
or dissertation chapter.
In all this, internship was
crucial to my research interest
in diasporic studies,
in that I had the opportunity
to challenge the narrative
of Connecticut as merely
the passive receiver
of Puerto Rican migrants.
Rather, Connecticut actively shaped
the very socioeconomic
conditions in Puerto Rico
which prompted migration to the mainland.
Likewise, gathering data
about the UPR strike
in 1981 enabled me to see the dynamism
of Puerto Rican student activism
in the late 20th century.
And even though mainland
and island student activists were fighting
for change an ocean apart,
or really, a sea apart from one another,
overlaps in their respective
advocacy demonstrate potential
for intra-communal
influence, however indirect.
Thank you very much for your time.
(audience clapping)
- [Steve] Questions?
Amanda, why don't you talk a little bit
about one of the most challenging features
of the research work you did?
- One of the most challenging features?
So, I think for me, Spanish
is my second language,
and while I knew going there
that I would need to brush up on it,
I think for sure it was
a challenge, you know,
both really trying to get a grasp
of the documents I was looking at,
and then also being able
to communicate confidently
with the fellow archivists.
I think, the first couple
weeks were just kind of trying
to psychologically wrap
my head around, okay,
it's gonna take time for the
Spanish to kind of pick up.
It's gonna take time for me
to really feel comfortable
with these archives and
that is part of this process
and it's an uncomfortable process,
but I need to be okay with that process.
So, yeah.
- [Steve] Thank you.
(audience clapping)
- Hey, everyone.
So, my tentative project is
called Corrugated Surrogacies,
Cardboard Kinships in the War in Vietnam.
And it looks at the history
of transnational migration
and adoption through the everyday object
of the cardboard box.
Projected here is a series of images
that sequence the
packaging and transporting
of Vietnamese orphans into
makeshift cardboard cribs
during Operation Babylift
at the end of the war in Vietnam in 1975.
So, Operation Babylift is
often narrated in paternalistic
and legalized discourses of
familial rescue and sacrifice.
Oftentimes, these narratives
take place as interviews with
or as oral histories
from adoptee survivors
of Operation Babylift
who have been able to
reunite with their families
and/or reflect upon their
experiences assimilating
to America.
These stories bookend Operation Babylift,
starting with 1975 and
following now into the present.
However, as much as these interviews
and oral histories index and
humanize refugee experiences
of memory, trauma and amnesia,
such genres of storytelling
are simultaneously delimiting
when considering the fact
that dozens of orphans
either died in transit
or that thousands of other
personal stories are lost
from the record as well.
So thus, I took this summer
to turn to the cardboard box
as my primary archival object of choice,
as a material that continues
to linger and litter
in the landfills and military
bases across transpacific
in order to re-narrate the
history of Operation Babylift.
By shifting our attention away
from the more obvious
contents of the cardboard box,
to instead the form of the crib itself,
I'm more interested in
extending this history
of Operation Babylift beyond 1975
as a means to trace a broader genealogy
of US militarism and its mechanisms.
By shifting our focus from the babies
to the boxes themselves,
we are able to spot a
minor but telling detail,
that of the V3C marker,
which is highlighted in the red circles.
This V3C label index is a
military grade cardboard box
specifically commissioned by and designed
for the US government
in the efficient transportation
of wartime goods,
meaning that the cribs that
you see here that were used
to house the orphans were
and still are the same cases
that are used to haul wartime supplies
such as ammunition and lunchbox
rations since World War II.
This subtle detail led me to a
series of university archives
from Cambridge to New York
with the support of RITM
and the WGSS program,
through which I learned that,
throughout the 20th century,
the United States commissioned a series
of material science engineers
and business academics and nutritionists
to constantly optimize the
production of cardboard.
Starting with the individual meal kits
the government constructed
to feed its soldiers since World War II
to the cardboard cribs used
to house its racialized victims
during the war in Vietnam,
the state sanctioned care
was not simply a matter
of ethics and emergencies.
Instead, it also involved a
careful calculation of finances
as markets and militarism intertwine
in the management of imperial intimacies.
As I continued to examine
how cardboard folds
across the history of empire,
I'm excited to continue this work
at the interdisciplinary intersections
between critical refugee
studies, supply chain studies,
and discard studies
as a means to understand
the ongoing effect
of cardboard as an ecological
as well as an epistemological structure.
Thank you.
(audience clapping)
- [Audience Member] How did
you get into this research?
How did you (indistinct)?
- Yeah, it was really serendipitous.
It was a class that I took with Jess,
actually, he's right next to you.
I studied the Vietnam War
normally through contemporary literature,
but it was just like looking at this,
we had an archival
project that we had to do,
like a quick like one
page story that we wrote,
and I just picked this image
'cause it was like the
first thing I could find
in my Google Drive.
But then upon relooking at it,
like I noticed that these
boxes were all the same shape
and I wanted to move away
from more standard oral history methods
and speculative methods.
So, yeah. Thanks so much.
(audience clapping)
- Hi, my name is Ming.
I'm a graduate student in
the Department of Psychology
and with support from the RITM,
I ran a study looking
at whether learning new
diagnostic information
about a person can change
people's initial face-based
implicit impressions
of competence for that person
and for people who share
similar facial features
and whether people do this
differently for targets
from different racial backgrounds,
and by implicit impressions,
we're referring to impressions
that are measured indirectly
and are less intentional
than explicit impressions,
which are measured directly
by asking people about their opinions.
So, in our study,
first, participants were introduced
to a competent looking target,
and depending on the condition,
the target was from one of
four different racial groups.
They then learned
either low competence
behavioral information,
or neutral information about the target
and completed a modified version
of the affect misattribution procedure,
which was used
to measure implicit
impressions of competence.
Because of time constraints,
I'll only present what we
found for Black targets
and for white targets here.
So, looking at the graphs,
the Y axis is the proportion
of more competent trials
in the affect misattribution procedure,
which you can just interpret
as people's implicit
impressions of competence.
So, higher values
indicate that the person,
that people found the person
to be high on competence
and the X axis is the prime type
in the affect misattribution procedure.
The target is denoted in green.
Other competent looking faces are in red,
and control faces are in blue.
So, the left half of both graphs is
when people learned low
competence behavioral information
about the target.
And the right half is
when people learned neutral information.
So, if we first look at the
right half of both graphs,
we see that the pattern is very similar
for both Black targets
and for white targets.
So when people learned neutral
information about the target,
they formed implicit impressions
of competence based on the face.
So, both the target
and other competent
looking faces were seen
as implicitly more competent
than control faces.
But when people learned
low competence information
about the target,
so now looking at the
left half of both graphs,
when the target was Black,
people did not change their impressions.
They still had a high
implicit competence impression
of the target and of other
competent looking faces.
However, when the target was white,
people did update their implicit
impressions of the target
in line with the new
behavioral information.
But learning low competence
behavioral information
about one competent looking person
did not influence their impressions
of other competent looking faces.
So, we're planning to run
another version of the study
with a larger sample to see
if the results would replicate
and to explore the possible mechanisms
behind this difference.
Thank you.
(audience clapping)
Yes?
- [Audience Member]
Thank you for this talk.
How are you measuring and
standardizing the information
that you were presenting?
How are you determining
what was low competence
versus (indistinct)?
- So, we did a number of pretests
before running the main study.
So, we came up with
four different vignettes
denoting low competence,
and we had independent raters on Prolific,
which is an online participant
recruitment platform
where we run our study to rate
the vignettes on competence
and then also a couple of other traits
which we controlled for.
(audience clapping)
- Hi, y'all.
So, in 1965, Al Raby,
a local civil rights leader in Chicago,
reflected on the last five
years of protest in a speech.
He said, "80 days and 72 marches ago,
the Chicago Freedom Movement
strode into high gear
when nearly 400 of us
occupied Chicago streets
and thoroughfare on our
way to tell Mayor Daley
to let superintendent Ben Willis go."
He continued, "I'm sure
that most of you realize
how important it is to
overcome here in Chicago.
If we win here,
it clears the way for liberation
of every Northern ghetto."
Raby, pictured here,
had spent the last five years as convener
of the Coordinating Council
of Community Organizations,
say that five times fast,
an umbrella group in
Chicago that coordinated
across the many civil rights
organizations in the city.
A former teacher in
Chicago Public Schools,
Raby was deeply devoted
to the power of education
as a liberatory mechanism.
He and others believed that
breaking into and approving,
improving Chicago's public
schools would lead to an opening
of the city more broadly.
But this fight for more equal
education didn't just start
in 1960.
In the Depression Era, so the 1930s,
Chicago schools took major
funding cuts across the board.
Schools in Chicago's Black neighborhoods,
mainly on the South Side of
the city, took the biggest hit.
This led to groups like the
NAACP and the Urban League
to really start rallying
around the issue of schools.
So, three major factors were involved
in sort of their fight again or fight
for better schools, I guess.
The first is that most of
these schools were districted
in a way that they were segregated.
So, given the segregation of neighborhoods
at the time as well,
it was sort of linked into that.
So, they wanted to redistrict
the schools across the city.
The second issue was curriculum.
So, same fight we're fighting now
for more true, honest
histories in classrooms,
things like that.
And then finally, the schools
were incredibly overcrowded.
So, this was in part due to the influx
during the great migration of Black folks
and in part due to just
the lack of building,
especially sort of in that Depression Era
when there just wasn't the
funding to do that building.
And so, as a result of that overcrowding,
you saw a lot of schools on double shifts.
So, that meant that half
of the students were going
to school in the morning,
half were going the afternoon,
and as you can imagine,
that left a lot of students
unsupervised throughout the day
and also missing, you know,
half of a day's education
across the board.
So, that was really one
of the biggest issues
and the issue that would hold through
through the rest of this movement.
Throughout the 1950s, you see
tensions continuing to grow,
certainly with Brown v. Board in 1954.
You see it not only in
Chicago but nationally,
this sort of school
segregation issue becoming more
and more of a big deal.
And Chicago's school
superintendent was Ben Willis
at the time,
was sort of considered the main target
of the civil rights
movement during this period,
again, in Chicago in particular.
So, he came into the city in 1953.
He built over a hundred schools.
So, on the one hand, he was
touted as this great builder
and being called this Big
Ben the Builder by some.
But on the other hand,
his policies continued to
implement segregation in school.
So he, instead of building a new school
in a Black neighborhood,
would put trailer classrooms
in the parking lot
or in the playground of that school
instead of building the new school.
So, he certainly was like
continuing segregation.
This all led to protests of Ben Willis,
daily marches on city
hall for an entire summer,
and in 1963 in October,
you see 250,000 students stay
out of school in a single day
for Freedom Day.
Those students, some of
them just stayed home,
some of them went to Freedom Schools,
sort of touting back to Mississippi
and the Freedom Schools there
during the civil rights movement.
And so, that's sort of the big peak
of my own research is
this freedom day movement.
So, I look at what came before
and what sort of came after.
Basically, we see this
big mass movement coming
into this freedom day time.
And after that, in 1966,
so a few years later,
Ben Willis, superintendent steps down.
Martin Luther King enters
the scene in Chicago,
starts fighting for fair housing,
and that's sort of how the story goes.
From there, we see,
obviously, schools are not
equal in Chicago still,
so the fight is still going,
but that's sort of the
civil rights era in a box
as far as Chicago schools go.
(audience clapping)
Yeah?
- [Audience Member] Thanks
for this presentation.
In studying the history
of like these sort of movements,
I was wondering if you
could see any sort of shared
or different positions
that student organizers
or parental organizers
played with each other
when like organizing the
walkouts or organizing?
- Yeah, so there's like
a lot of different groups
that play in Chicago,
for sure and across the board,
but certainly in Chicago,
there's different neighborhoods,
there's different groups of people.
You see teachers organizing.
You see students organizing.
You see parents organizing, you see,
and then you sort of see
these like civil rights people
who they're like professional organizers,
some of them, right?
And so, with students,
I think you see them
fighting really particularly
in the later period for the most part,
so in the sort of '65, '66 era.
But you start to see
high schoolers starting
to fight really hard in those
issues of like curriculum
or they want better lunchrooms,
so really distinct things I
guess as opposed to these,
civil rights organizations
that are a little more broad
in what they want, right?
They wanna change the policies
in the city and these other,
like the high schoolers, for example,
really wanna fix the one
thing that's happening
in their high school.
So that's, I guess, the
biggest difference I would say.
(audience clapping)
- So hi, everyone. I'm Anqi.
I'm a second year master student
in the council of East Asian
studies pursuing anthropology.
Today, I want to quickly walk
through my ethnographic field work
exploring African migrants'
experiences in Yiwu, China.
So first, where and what is Yiwu?
Yiwu is one of the satellite cities
of the metropolis Shanghai.
It is not a big city,
but it has the largest
wholesale market in the world
with over 75,000 stores.
Not surprisingly, Yiwu is a
gathering place for traders,
especially those from affluent countries
seeking cheap made-in-China goods.
In 2018, there were
over 3,000 African permanent
residents living there.
But the pandemic has changed many things.
Many African traders were either deported
or voluntarily left
because of China's COVID
containment policies.
My own research was forced to end early
due to a sudden lockdown in the city.
Still, for one and a half months,
I worked with African
traders from Nigeria, Ghana,
Benin, Uganda, Somali and Senegal,
and used participant observation
and semi-structured interviews
to understand their migratory experiences.
First, what my informant
and I discussed most
were the insecurities,
anxiety over mobility.
China's travel ban has
prevented non-citizens
from entering the countries
while these traders
work hinges on mobility.
Running logistics businesses,
they used to receive African buyers flying
to China frequently.
However, as no more buyers
are traveling to China
and online wholesale entities
such as Alibaba have expanded
into African countries,
many of these traders
expressed a sense of precarity,
seeing their position as
middle men destabilized.
But I found that, by
maintaining good reputation
and capitalizing on the mutual suspicion
between African clients and
Chinese business owners,
these middlemen were still
able to navigate the pandemic
because of their social capital.
Race and racism also
emerged as central topics.
In my work,
rather than treating
race as a static notion,
I study it as an interactive process
in which different groups
of people interacts
in a highly contingent manner
that shapes the idea of
race and racial experiences.
In Yiwu, I found that racism,
especially against African males,
has been linked to mythologies
about Black males' hypersexuality.
At the same time,
even though many Chinese
business owners see the presence
of African traders as a hallmark
of China's globalization,
they also treat the presence of Blackness
as a sign of China's
temporary entanglements
with the third world and even barbarianism
that needs to be eradicated
in order to fulfill their fantasy
of China becoming a first world country.
Despite my short time in Yiwu,
the topics I explore there are ones
that I will continue to
explore in my MA thesis.
Thank you so much.
(audience clapping)
- [Audience Member] I just wanna know
what the sort of challenges were
of doing this research,
especially with COVID and everything else.
- I think, in terms of travel ban policies
to overcame the 21 days,
21 days mandatory quarantine in hotel
and then go to the city
and then also facing the
sudden lockdown in the city.
Yeah, so it was pretty
hectic, but at a same, I also,
I have to negotiate my positionality
as a female young scholars,
because I constantly receive like warnings
from Chinese people regarding
the thing I talk about,
which is like African
males' hypersexuality.
So, actually, so that's why I think that,
rather than studying race
as a really static notion,
I wanna see like how
people interact together
and constructs the idea of
race and racism together.
Yeah, though I think that is
two of my main challenges.
Yeah. Thank you.
(audience clapping)
- Hi, everyone. My name's Babette.
I am a second year
in the departments of African
American and American studies.
So, my work this summer actually
changed course quite a bit
from what I originally mapped out.
I was supposed to do some research
at this archival collection
at Fisk University
and had confirmed my appointment
at the beginning of the summer,
but they had a change in management
and were no longer accepting appointments
until late fall.
So, I'm left with this
flight from JFK to Nashville
and this reservation at a three star motel
that I'm not really completely
sure what to do with.
I'm happy to say
that what I was able to
come up with is something
that I've been wanting to do for years
and that I think ultimately
really helped advance some
of my research on my analysis
of southern Black radio programs
in the mid to late 20th century.
But before I get into that,
I think it's important to back up
and give a little
background on my research.
One of the main radio stations
that I look at in my research is WDIA,
which is the first all Black
programmed radio station
to go on the air in the US in
1948 in Memphis, Tennessee.
So in my research, I
analyze recordings of WDIA
and draw up the intimate relationships
between Black hosts and
Black Memphis listeners.
I analyzed these recordings
through the lens of affect
and haptic theory and
think about what it means
that WDIA provided material comfort
to those living amidst the
state sanctioned violence
of a segregationist regime.
For example,
one recording in particular in
this collection of recordings
that I listened to is an oral history
with a woman named Jo Evelyn Grayson.
Jo Evelyn Grayson has now passed on,
but I believe she was 40 at
the time of this recording.
And she talks about how, as
a kid growing up in Memphis,
WDIA is what she heard in the morning
as well as in the evening
when she went back to sleep.
It completely framed her day.
Jo Evelyn Grayson was
born in 1948 in Memphis,
living in one of the five
or so Black neighborhoods
in Memphis at the time.
This is also the same year
that someone very special was born,
Black feminist scholar and literary
and cultural theorist, Hortense Spillers,
who was also born in a Black
neighborhood in Memphis.
During Professor
Spillers' time in college,
while she was protesting
for the integration
of diners through sit-ins,
Hortense Spillers or Tensi
as her family calls her,
also found the time to
be a radio DJ at WDIA.
She was one of the few
women to work at the station
at the time in the '60s
and she had a music segment every weekend
where she played songs
and talked on the air,
going by the name of Honey Girl.
Sitting in her Nashville home,
Professor Spillers has me
buckling over in laughter
at her impersonation of a
white manager at the station
with a big overbite who she
wasn't particularly fond of.
She provides me insight into
how she navigated the station
as a dark skinned Black woman
and how in some ways she felt
that the men at the station
actually protected her.
But she also confirmed
some of my suspicions
that the station was not
as outwardly political
as I had hoped,
that nobody other than
her really made statements
about segregation on the air.
I'm so deeply grateful
to have spent this time
conducting this oral history
with Professor Spillers,
a fellow radio producer and DJ.
I don't believe there's
any other published
or written work about her time at WDIA.
So, I'm excited to not only
include this in my research,
but also to continue
working with the archivists
at Brown University to have
this oral history included
with her collection of papers.
I was so happy to learn
also that Jo Evelyn Grayson,
the woman whose recordings
I have now listened to
for hours and hours
and Professor Spillers had
actually known each other
and gone to school together
at Booker T. Washington High
and Memphis University.
She leaned back and said,
"Yes, of course I knew her"
when I brought up her name.
Thank you so much.
(audience clapping)
Yeah, go for it.
- [Audience Member] This is
so exciting to hear about.
I was just curious, like does
WDIA have any like archives?
- Yeah, so most of the collections
from WDIA are held at Indiana University,
and a lot of them are digitized,
which is really nice.
So, the stuff of Jo Evelyn
Grayson is like online.
I don't think the radio station itself
has very well organized archives,
but Indiana University has some of them.
Yeah. Awesome.
Thank you so much.
(audience clapping)
- Hi, everybody. So
before, does this work?
Oh, okay.
Before I start,
I wanted to quickly just
give a brief background
to essentially my project and,
yeah, just kind of, and
also my, what I do here.
So, I am a second year PhD
student in anthropology.
I also will be taking
the WGSS certificate.
So yeah, my larger
project, as you can see,
so who, oh, you're actually starting?
Oh, okay.
I didn't realize. Okay.
So, my project is about Black
British gay and queer cis men
and how they negotiate space and place
in the gay community.
So, I'm interested in their experiences
within certain gay and queer spaces,
but also what it means to
be Black, British and gay
in the 21st century,
so their experiences more broadly.
So, I'm gonna be talking
particularly about this day
and this particular,
so this is just a picture
I got from Google.
So, but I was,
yeah, so this is an old picture.
But anyway,
so, this particular thing I'm gonna talk
about is just research and fun
and a fun Saturday night
out in unexpected places.
So, I didn't expect
this particular research
that took place to happen.
And then for the people that I spoke to,
my interlocutors, this
was a Saturday night
in what I call an unexpected place.
So basically, it was a Saturday evening.
I, it was August, I was
about to come back to the US
and I needed a suitcase.
So, I went to Central London
and a particular place
called Oxford Street,
went to a particular
store, it was closing,
wanted to see if I could get big suitcase.
There was no luck.
So I thought, let me go down to Soho,
which is a particular area in London
and this is called Old Compton Street.
So, there's a lot of gay,
it's a gay area along here,
also, like just lots of gay
spaces and clubs and bars.
Anyway, so I was walking down the street,
I went to this bar and
I just stood outside
and was watching and
wanted to see if, you know,
I could interact with people.
But it was very, very busy.
It was late at night, like
10 o'clock in the evening.
Anyway, I decided to walk down this street
and just here, in the corner here,
I saw three Black people standing there,
so two Black guys and a girl.
And so, I walked past and I was like,
I need to talk to them.
But I was a bit, you know, scared.
So, I walked past and then I
came back and I spoke to them.
Anyway, we started
speaking and I, you know,
tell them about my research.
One of them was a bit, you know,
kind of like, not sure,
was looking at me like,
what's this guy talking about?
And then another one was, you know,
a bit more enthusiastic,
and the other one was
just a bit more quiet.
Anyway, I asked them what they were doing.
I told 'em about my project
and they told me that they
were just standing there
like talking, having
drinks, blah, blah, blah.
There was an intention
to go out somewhere.
Anyway, in the end, I found out
that they didn't go anywhere
and they stood there for the whole night,
just having a conversation, talking,
having fun and drinking.
So, basically the point of
this presentation today was
to essentially highlight the fact that,
actually, you can find,
you can find research happen, sorry,
activity happening in spaces
that you don't expect.
So, I didn't expect to go
and find that people
will be here having fun.
They were, that was their night out.
They were in the corner
just kind of having fun.
Amongst a busy, busy night,
where so much was going on,
they were just there talking
to each other, having fun.
So essentially, I didn't
expect to find that.
And I think that's also
something that I've realized
in terms of like thinking
about space and place
and thinking about where
you're gonna find research
and where people enjoy themselves.
It's made me think anew
about those kind of concepts
and where you can find research
and where people might enjoy themselves.
Because of the time,
I can't go into too much
detail, but yeah, thank you.
That's essentially what happened.
(audience clapping)
- [Steve] Roy, did this
change any of your thinking
about your project?
- Yes, it did, because I,
as I said, I didn't expect,
- Pick up the mic.
- Use the mic.
- Oh, sorry.
Yes, it did, 'cause I didn't expect,
as I was saying, to find,
I didn't think about the street
as a site of research, basically.
I, you know, I went initially to,
on this street, there's a like
a bar or club called G-A-Y,
which is quite famous actually.
And I stood out, I was gonna go inside,
but I stood outside just
kind of like watching,
and yeah, just seeing
if I'd be able to speak
to people coming out or going in even.
So anyway, there was no luck there
and I decided to just
walk around the street,
just to kind of observe what was going on.
And then I just saw those
three individuals there,
and that particular corner,
it was quite significant
because it was just in the
midst of so much going on,
they were just standing there.
You probably wouldn't
maybe even notice had,
if I wasn't paying attention,
I probably wouldn't have even noticed.
So, it has changed my mind in the sense
of maybe going around, when
I walk on these streets,
to maybe I actually just speak to people
on the street instead
and I never thought about that.
And so, it's got me thinking
about maybe observing more street action
because a lot of things actually
do happen on the street.
So yeah, there was more
to the story as well,
but obviously, I didn't have as much time.
But it definitely has made me think anew
about different spaces
in which you can, yeah,
research and maybe even
find interlocutors.
So, thank you.
(audience clapping)
- Hi, everyone, my name's Thomas,
and I'm a second year, and PhD,
in history of science and
medicine and early modern studies.
So, what if I told you
that poisonous snakes,
infectious diseases like rabies
and transatlantic chattel
slavery all converged
in the development and collection of some
of the world's first
standardized sets of biomarkers?
These seemingly disparate
forces came into contact
with each other in the Colonial Atlantic,
and my project seeks to investigate
and understand the fallout
of those encounters.
For the purposes of today's talk,
I ask us to specifically consider 16th
to 19th century European
colonizing enterprises
in the Caribbean.
These historical events
brought many different people
from far flung places together,
and one of the key
ramifications of these meetings,
from an epidemiological perspective,
was the increasingly frequent outbreak
of seemingly novel diseases
from a European perspective.
In this light, the Caribbean,
a site of varied and intertwined
histories of domination
and subjugation of enslaved
peoples was often described
as an inhospitable place filled
with disease and suffering.
But it was also a location
of great opportunity
from a European colonizing perspective.
And outside of familiar histories
of the search for gold and silver
or the establishment of a
brutal plantation complex,
the Caribbean also served as
an excellent testing ground
for new medical theories and treatments.
The reasons for this were manifold.
There were a greater number of diseases
to examine than there were in Europe.
The enslaved African population
provided a ready-made class
of unconsenting test subjects,
and the lush island topography presented
plentiful new plants and animals
with which medical professionals
could fashion new drugs.
Therefore, Caribbean colonialism fostered
and encouraged medical innovation
on a large scale, I argue.
The findings from my
recent archival research,
one page of which you
will see on the top right
of the screen here,
demonstrate a concerted effort
to collect enormous sets
of medical data
that linked patients'
biographical information
alongside their maladies,
as well as data about the time of year
and environmental conditions,
such as temperature and
barometric pressure.
These sources indicate a
sophisticated level of thinking
about the social and environmental
determinants of health
in the Colonial Caribbean,
something that biomedicine
today still struggles
to get its head wrapped around.
I also found more fraught
evidence of human experimentation
with poisons on terminally ill patients.
Specifically, French
physicians conducted a series
of experiments with viper's
venom on rabies patients
in the 1760s, the findings of which
eventually helped Louis Pasteur develop
the first rabies vaccine.
The venom was derived
from the lancehead viper
from Martinique, where it was used
in exploitative experiments
and to torture enslaved Africans.
Here we see how poison
was simultaneously a tool
of subjugation in the Caribbean
and a miraculous medicament in Europe.
From this brief overview,
I'll leave you with one simple question.
How might these entangled histories
of slavery, experimentation,
and medical innovation
give us pause in believing
in the infallibility
of the modern medicine
that they helped create?
Thank you.
(audience clapping)
- [Audience Member] So I see
a picture there in the corner,
but like what are some
of the kind of like archival like sources
and documents that you used
to like think about like this?
- Yeah, so it's a variety of things
from treatises on like
what a disease actually is
and how you might get infected
because that was up for debate,
but also, these statistical tables
based on trying to like
determine whether climate
actually does impact somebody's
susceptibility to disease
and then also transcripts
from medical experimentations themselves.
Yeah.
- [Steve] Thanks.
(audience clapping)
- Good afternoon, everyone.
My name is Abigail Calderon.
I am a second year history
student in the PhD.
I focused on Latinx
businesses in the 20th century
as social, cultural and political anchors.
This summer with the help of RITM,
I explored the Roybal Edward Papers
and the Bradley Mayor
Tom Administration Papers
at the University of
California, Los Angeles.
I wanted to take the opportunity
to examine these collections
in conjunction to research the period
between the Federal Highway Act of 1956
and the Rebuild LA Program
created by then Mayor Tom Bradley
to rebuild Los Angeles after
the Los Angeles uprisings
in order to study urban
disinvestment and reinvestment,
specifically how Latinx and
small businesses reacted
to changes in government spending.
Although I had intended
to spend equal amounts
of time on both collections,
I ended up focusing a majority of my time
on the Bradley collection
because it centered businesses
as a backbone of Los Angeles.
With this, three different themes emerged.
One was the language that the
City of Los Angeles employed
after the Los Angeles uprisings
in order to establish diversity
as a positive strength
and itself as a microcosm of the nation
in order to continue to attract business.
Two was how they treated
the homeless population
during their efforts
to recentralize LA's
downtown business district.
And finally how Latinx
businesses were writing
to express different social
and political concerns
during this time.
For instance, I included a letter
from the Mexican Grocers Association
that wrote to express discontent
after a government agent from
the INS came to give a talk
and implied that immigrants
were drug dealers.
This is exemplary of different,
of how different businesses
were not only writing
about fiscal concerns,
but also about social
and political concerns.
Overall, my summer research,
specifically on the Bradley collection,
helped me identify different stakeholders
amongst Latinx businesses
and how the city was
attempting to rebrand itself
to continue attracting business,
and finally, how it was
prioritizing different businesses
and different people
in order to attempt to recentralize.
And the Roybal collection
allowed me to get some context
on the Federal Highway Act.
Thank you very much.
(audience clapping)
- [Audience Member] Are there, was there
any particular thread
that you like may not
have been looking for
when you were kinda
coming into the archive,
but that you're hoping
to kinda further explore
now that you've come across these sources
and found what you found?
- Yeah, so one thing that
I was not at all expecting
to find was conversations on Skid Row
and the homeless
population in Los Angeles.
I was originally intending to
look at the recentralization
of the business district and
how it affected businesses
and the communities they served.
But what I ended up finding was a lot
on sort of the homeless population
and how the city was sort
of talking about them.
And it was a really interesting language
around like quote unquote,
like a "Skid Row mentality."
And so, I think that even
though it's not directly related
to my research, I'm,
I wanna explore that
because I think it really sort of lays out
the city's priorities.
(audience clapping)
- Hi, everyone. Thank you for being here.
My name is Jess and I'm a second year
in the history department
and I'm gonna be presenting on
some of the archival material
that I saw this summer
while I was back home
at the University of Miami
at the Cuban Heritage
Collection specifically.
So, pictured here are some
donation cards that were mainly
in circulation spanning through the 1960s
up until the 1980s,
which were considered the peak
years of (speaking Spanish)
or the war across the paths of the world,
or kind of like the war against communism
across Latin America and the
Caribbean as it was deployed
by anti-Castro Cuban exile
terrorist organizations.
So I'm gonna be focusing on
(speaking Spanish) today,
which is all of the donation bonds,
kind of they're all sponsored
by that organization specifically,
which was founded in 1961.
And the organization
whose collection had like,
the most amount of boxes
that I was able to focus
on the most this summer.
So, with chapters across
the United States,
Venezuela, Puerto Rico,
(speaking Spanish) membership
was made up of Cuban exiles
that were central to the war,
to the US's war against the island
throughout the late 1950s
and 1960s and up until today,
and many of them directly
trained by the CIA,
were directly trained by
the CIA with involvement
and were involved in the orchestrating
of the Bay of Pigs invasion in 1961.
And also a lot of the men
that these funds are
kind of being donated for
were men that were also involved
in like the first couple of years
of the July 26th movement
leading up to the triumph
of the Cuban Revolution and
abandoned soon afterwards.
And what I'm attempting to begin arguing
through the analysis
of these donation cards
and also kind of a lot of
the other things that I saw,
which were kind of like
these letters to presidents,
ambassadors and other politicians
across Latin America and the Caribbean,
is how, rather than weaken
after the CIA ceased
to fund (speaking Spanish) publicly,
these organizations
became more transnational.
So, in the sense that they
began to see their perpetual war
against the Cuban Revolution
as one that began to encompass the urgency
to contain communism
across the hemisphere.
So, the funds collected
through these donation cards,
either directly or indirectly,
helped facilitate the exportation
of these tactics of terror,
these skills that they were
trained through the CIA with.
And some of these examples
that I saw were kind of
like bomb construction,
kidnappings, assassinations, boat attacks,
and also the legal defense of Cuban exiles
that were detained after
these acts by the governments
where most of these acts of
terrorism were carried out
or kind of organized.
And some examples being Venezuela,
Puerto Rico, Chile and Mexico.
And one of the examples is
kind of like the donation bond
that's all the way to the right,
wait, your left,
and kind of the way
that a lot of Cuban exiles were advocating
for the extradition of
Orlando Bosch who was one of,
at the time was
responsible for the bombing
of the Cubana Flight 455 in 1976.
And the Venezuelan
government had detained Bosch
for 11 years.
So, some of the questions
that I'm thinking
about is the language that is
used in these donation cards
and how Cuban exiles were reacting
to these acts of terrorism,
both Cuban migrants that were
living across Latin America
and the Caribbean,
specifically Costa Rica, Panama, Venezuela
during the 1970s and the 1980s,
and how exiles in the US were
also reacting to those trials.
And the questions that
I'm kind of left with is,
how do these bonds show
what executive members
of (speaking Spanish) saw this recovery,
to entail this recovery of Cuba?
And yeah, kind of tracing
what invasion meant,
what invading Cuba meant
throughout the 1970s and the 1980s
and how it involved right wing movements
in countries like Venezuela,
Costa Rica and Panama.
Sorry, that was really quick.
Thank you.
(audience clapping)
- [Audience Member] This is so cool.
I love the, like your archival study here.
I was wondering if you
could just, you know,
share more about some of
your initial observations
about the differences or
similarities in language
across all of these various archives.
And maybe a few thoughts
on like the different iconography too.
- Yeah, so one of,
- Use the mic.
- Oh.
Sorry.
So, one of the things that I see a lot of
and like it's something
that I would wanna flesh out is the way
that they use like Jose Marti quotes
and the way that they use images
of like the war of it,
like the independence wars in Cuba
and kind of how they appropriate,
how they appropriate them.
So kind of like (speaking Spanish)
kind of using a, the kind of,
the kind of the gun, also
using just even kind of like,
like just using kind of like a dollar,
like not a dollar bill,
like the idea of like a dollar bill
and kind of how they're thinking
about Cuban exile nationalism
or whatever that means
in connection with these independence wars
and how it's like this perpetual war
that they are continuing
from Cuban independence.
So, I think that's kind of something
that I saw that really connected.
Yeah, I'm trying to think of other things,
but I think that's kind of one thread
that I'm thinking a lot about right now.
Thank you for asking.
(audience clapping)
- Hi, I'm Sylvia Ryerson.
I'm a fifth year PhD in American Studies
and the RITM Summer Research Fellowship
supported three months of ethnographic
and archival research
in Southwest Virginia
and Eastern Kentucky for
my dissertation project,
Calls from Home,
Listening Past Carceral
Power in Central Appalachia.
And so, from the end of May
until August, through August,
I was based in Harlan County, Kentucky,
pursuing multiple threads
of my dissertation project.
And so, I wanted to share
this image for my presentation
because one of the highlights
of my summer was getting to work with
and learn from the Higher
Ground Theater Company,
which is based out of the local
community college in Harlan.
And this is an image from their work,
which I really think captures
their community based
methodologies and practice.
And so, the man in the black
shirt is Bennie Massey,
who is a former underground coal miner
and a beloved community activist
who lives in the small
town of Lynch, Kentucky,
and who I was able to interview
and learn from this summer.
And so, Lynch was built by
the US Coal and Coke Company,
which was a subsidiary of US Steel,
which was built as a company owned town
to house coal miners and
their families in 1917.
It was a segregated coal camp
that became the destination
for thousands of Black families
during the first wave
of the great migration
from the Deep South,
as coal company recruiters went to Alabama
and neighboring states to entice
or coerce former sharecroppers
and convict lease miners
to come work as waged laborers
in the Kentucky coal fields.
And despite unsafe,
exploitative and racist living
and working conditions,
Black miners and their
families turned this corner
of Southeast Kentucky into
a powerful cultural center
with deep roots in the region.
And alongside my research in Lynch,
I actually was able to serve
as a teaching assistant
for a 12 week summer course
that the Higher Ground
Theater Company was teaching
in the Harlan County Jail,
serving as an assistant for
their Appalachian studies class
and learning from and with the people
in the Harlan County
Jail about the conditions
of their life and
incarceration in Harlan County.
And so, the support from RITM
really made it possible for me
to be in the community for
such an extended amount of time
and really able to work
closely and collaboratively
with the scholars and
artists in the region
who are doing such important work
and who made so many of my
own connections possible.
And additionally, I was very fortunate
to receive an RITM
conference travel award,
which supported my travel to Indiana
to give a paper presentation
at the American Political
Histories Conference
titled the Past, Present and Future
of American Democracy
at Purdue University,
where I presented as a part
of a paper panel session
on Appalachia and energy politics
with other Appalachian scholars.
Thanks.
(audience clapping)
- [Steve] Sylvia, could
you say a little bit more
about the project?
- Yeah, yeah.
And so, I sort of had to jump between two,
really, I was sort of,
the research I was doing
in Lynch is sort of part
of chapter two of the dissertation
and then teaching in the
Harlan County Jail is part
of chapter five.
And it's looking at these different nodes
of the carceral state
in Central Appalachia,
including state prisons, federal prisons,
the county jail,
and tracing that back to the roots
of convict lease labor in Alabama.
And so, and obviously
the afterlives of slavery
and many other systems of
extraction in the region.
And so, I think, in a way,
what I was trying to balance
and what sort of both
histories are present
in Harlan County is both these deep roots
of Black migration into Appalachia
and sort of how race relations in the,
at the turn of the century
structured labor relations
in Appalachia throughout the century.
And then also how, you know,
those foundations have
also created the conditions
of possibility for the
kind of jail expansion
that's happening there today.
(audience clapping)
- Hello.
My name's Josh. I'm a
second year history PhD.
My research focuses on
modern intellectual history
and specifically the
changing debate about race
and the place of Jews in post-war Europe
among largely francophone intellectuals
roughly in the timeframe
between the Algerian War of Independence
and the 1967 war in Israel Palestine.
I used my RITM summer travel
grant to go to a conference
that was called Hijacking
a Memory in Berlin.
It was, according to the organizers,
probably one of the first conferences held
in post-war Germany that
directly discussed the Holocaust
and colonial violence
together on the same stage.
This is a major taboo in German culture.
It's because there is a
complicated political legacy
about relativizing the Holocaust.
In German culture,
the Holocaust is the greatest evil
that humanity ever carried out
and nothing can ever be compared to it.
And in some places,
intellectuals who compare,
say, the ethnic cleansing of
Palestine during the Nakba
or German violence in its African colonies
to the Holocaust actually can
face really serious academic
and professional consequences.
So, there was a little bit
of an (speaking in
foreign language) element
to the conference,
but there was also like
proximate political reasons
for it being held there as well,
which is that, in Europe,
the new right has sort
of flipped the valence
of anti-Semitism.
So, whereas say before 1980,
what it meant to be on the far right
in Europe was to be bluntly anti-Semitic.
Now, the xenophobic far right in Germany
and in France and
elsewhere, Poland, Hungary,
has used a kind of phylo-Semitic argument
to block the flow of immigrants from,
largely from the Middle East.
So for instance, in Germany, the AfD,
which is in some sense
the sort of successor
of neo-Nazi parties has opposed
the German government's immigration plans
to have Syrian refugees come,
on the grounds that the
Syrian refugees are going
to bring in anti-Semitism into Germany.
And so, all of this was being
discussed at the conference
and what ended up happening
was that the controversy
that the conference was meant to address
actually blew up during the conference.
And two Polish academics
criticized publicly
and went to the German press
over the remarks of a Palestinian scholar
named Tareq Baconi who
explicitly compared the Nakba
to the Holocaust.
And this kind of, there
was a media fire storm
in Germany over this.
Right wing German politicians
called for the defunding
of the venue where the
conference was held,
which is called the
House of World Cultures.
And I ended up covering
this for a magazine
that I work for called Jewish Currents,
which the article was called,
The Challenge of Defending
Memory in Germany,
which was about the sort of
new politics of anti-Semitism
or anti anti-Semitism
and how they're connected
to xenophobia and Europe immigration
and the legacies of colonialism.
And that's it.
(audience clapping)
Go ahead.
- [Audience Member] This
is two prong question.
What happened to the (indistinct)
and do you, in terms of Germany's stance,
do you know other (indistinct)
compared to the Holocaust,
I wonder if you could maybe
talk about why that might be,
considering you mentioned things
that happened in East Africa and genocides
that happened before that,
and why that might maybe how they navigate
those kind of histories,
the histories that came before?
- Yeah, so Tareq was, ended up being fine,
and a lot of the conference participants
who were there signed a petition
kind of in support of him.
And there ended up,
it turned out that he had
a lot of support there
and it did,
I don't think it had severe
consequences on his life.
He runs a Palestinian think
tank called Al-Shabaka
which you should all check out
if you're interested in that sort of thing
where they are probably
at the cutting edge
of Palestinian politics.
As for like the German sort
of relativization debate,
this sort of, it blew
up in the '80s at first
because initially the
comparisons were between,
was it possible to compare
the Soviet gulag system
to the Nazi camp system?
That was like what was sort
of the first historians debate
in Germany, and that's
kind of where things were.
And you know, generally it
was a far right talking point
to compare because right wingers who maybe
or maybe not had some kind of
Nazi affiliation were saying,
look, the communists also had camps.
So it's not just the Nazi thing,
it was also a,
it's like there were
bad guys on both sides.
That's the background for why the politics
of comparison is very hard.
But also, the part of
Germany's rehabilitation
into the Family of Nations
after its unification has entailed
the German state being explicitly Zionist.
So, part of the Germans,
what Germany conceives of
as its national interest is the protection
of the sovereign State of Israel.
And so, that makes,
say, discourse about the
Palestinians or really any kind
of anti-colonial politics,
not just kind of,
it makes it a threat to
what the state has conceived
of as its raison d'etre, basically.
(audience clapping)
- All right. Thank you, Josh.
Thank you, everybody.
Really appreciate all the
presenters sharing their work.
You know, this is the kind of work
that we want to continue to support,
so we hope you will come back
and continue to seek support here in RITM.
In that spirit, I'll also invite you
to come on Wednesdays.
We have writing Wednesdays
from 9:30 to 11:30
and 10 in the weeks to come
to have coffee and breakfast food
and hope that you and
others will gather here
and do some of your own writing
and that you'll continue
to see one another
because I think one of the
things that I so appreciate
in listening to you is the
reminder of how much we all have
to learn from one another,
that after all, much of our
education really does come from,
come horizontally, if you
wanna think about it that way,
from one's peers and the
people who are doing some
of the most important research on campus.
So with that, thank you so much.
We invite you out.
We actually have some food for you
and we hope that you can
continue the conversation there.
Thanks again.
(audience clapping)
(gentle music)